il y a plus de 300 ans louis xiv et
cultiver ses fruits et légumes préférés
comme les fraises ou les asperges au
potager du roi on cultive aujourd'hui
près de 800 variétés en trouvant si
j'ose dire un écosystème en nous
trouvons un espace dans laquelle nous
trouvons nous cherchons un équilibre
entre produire et prélevées entre
produire et
et rendre un espace beau en fait aussi
bien plus que ça parce que les deux
parce que le potager est une école
depuis la révolution française il y à
eut installé dans ce jardin des écoles
successifs et donc aujourd'hui nous
formons les futurs paysagistes pour le
potager c'était aussi les premières
ouvertures du week-end est la seule
gratuite de l'année on apprécie
l'endroit l'histoire de l'endroit ce
lieu qui était dessinée qui a été depuis
de longues années qui servait de garde
manger là pour un seul monsieur un peu
riches les orties crever de faim à on a
trouvé ça très beau c'est assez
impressionnant comme lieu c'est vraiment
magnifique
il ya des poulaillers il ya des beaucoup
de pommiers le potager du roi ouvrait
ses portes pour la seconde fois pur
esprit jardin